hi I'm Colin McNeill for the score
eSports in league of legends first blood
needs a bump in gold some early momentum
and most importantly one team's chance
to set the tone for the rest of the game
from bjergsen's emphatic start to his NA
career to SK T's five-on-five attack
against KT in 2013 here are the most
intense game breaking first blood kills
in League of Legends competitive history
bjergsen didn't waste any time making
his mark with team solomid after a
strong showing and EU with the
copenhagen wolves he became one of the
first EU tô na imports in his first ever
game with TSM at Battle of the Atlantic
he secured first blood on the block to
mark his arrival in North America you
forced to use a teleport because of
Erickson trying to go hard the ignited
side the first God three minutes and 25
seconds city already puts himself on the
board in the 2017 worlds group stage
cloud nines contracts and Jensen thought
they'd try to get an early edge by
positioning for a gank on faker but that
plan didn't work out as well as they'd
hoped
contracts now in trouble faker pushing
for a little bit more is he gonna get
the first super clean out during last
year's EU LCS summer third-place match
he took nuclear's cross map ash arrow to
get the action started fed then followed
up by landing a Corki package and
expertly turned his back to the
Cassiopeia alt to seal the deal for his
life my admin comes in the flash over
the wall amazing patience one more
rocket baby flash in burst blood
beautiful play from Feb event he was
waiting for the ultimate during the 2017
MSI Finals g2 sparks look to send faker
a message early in the game perks was
able to land a critical knock back and
chase faker
over the wall to take out the best
player in the world
here comes a play in the banker
exhausting sake
incredibly the 2014 World Championship
finals started off with a bang a star
horn Royal Club and Samsung white
started a 5v5 teamfight at level 1 just
over a minute into the game these two
aggressive juggernaut stayed true to
their reputations and this time Samsung
came out with the first blood kill on
their way to a world title takes that
jump first rocket jump is going to beat
out
during the 2016 GU LCS spring split
feather than showed off some crafty
mechanics to pick up a first blood for
fnatic he set up to bait the threshold
from Nisbet and then led him straight
into the rest of the fnatic squad or you
guessed it the first blood a lot of you
might remember this game for the faker
versus reuse ed outplay but it also
started with a massive 5v5 teamfight
over first blood an emphatic start to
the final game in what was one of the
best League of Legends matches of all
time who's gonna go down bet
Oh bris blood first blood goes to insect
gets it next we have yet another major
eSports moment that began with an
impressive first blood team w we
defeated GE Tigers at IEM 2015 and what
was one of the biggest upsets in League
of Legends history
Kuro just got a little too greedy and
spirit and she ate took full advantage
for a clean kill or that may be the
chance 206 girl has to
- spirit great game great charm gujiya
in one of the most competitive
best-of-five matches of all time the Rox
Tigers pushed SKT to the brink with
their off meta misfortune pic in Game
three of the 2016 World semi finals
picking up first blood and redefining
the meta also worth noting and sort of
sort of par for the course a little
forth here's the jump in a few more
attacks we'll do it
in another example of an underdog team
almost coming out on top against SKT
misfits insane fervor Leona Peck in Game
three of last year's World Championship
resulted in ignore securing a first
blood and two kills against the best
team in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay that's our list but what about
yours
if you've got a sick first blood play
that didn't make it into our top ten
tell us in the comments below
but don't flame us too hard okay thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button